[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu ce que la presse appelle en
tout cas d'être là il est il est poussé
à l'aise les classes
vous savez les tièdes ça ne commence à
se passionner guillaume comment ça se
passe et enregistrement de questions
pour un champion aux proches tient en
fait c'est très frustrant parce que
j'entends que faisait beau et bon
travail des beaux mais pardonnez moi
guillemets rotenberg et ouais t'es
gonfler parce que pour une fois qu'on
s'est croisé europe 1 je t'ai demandé
c'était marié et puis tu marc webb
[Applaudissements]
attendez la baule s'est marié lui un
jeune héros on la voit ça comme moi
c'est ce que le mois un renoi jury
jeunes mariés non séparés mais juin
j'ai marié ouais je suis un vrai rôle
arabe mais je suis passé à côté
ouais mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est
vous êtes passé à côté de 2,2 hors de
vraiment ses blessures et bien vous
ressemble c'est vrai vous auriez eu des
gros enfin temps
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]